winning the bid for the 2016 Olympics
Rio de
Cano was something all Brazilians could
celebrate but winning the construction
bids to build the vast Olympics
infrastructure is proving profitable for
just a small number of Brazilian
construction companies we are moving
from a very
complicated phase Mauricio Cruz Lopez is
the man responsible for the enormous new
Olympic Village known as Ilia Pura is
that a lot of pressure a lot of pressure
our company it's specialized in a lot of
pressure projects that company called OD
brch is Latin America's biggest Builder
and has partnered with a local developer
to finance these seven giant
Condominiums there are 7,000 workers on
site today during the Olympic Games
18,000 athletes will stay here and then
6 months later oder BR intends to sell
these 3500 Apartments to wealthy Rio
families for as much as $800,000
each we have a lot of people buying this
kind of apartment so it was possible to
to make a private uh business here but
privately owned OD BR has more often
relied on public money to build in
Brazil everything from ports to roads
oil platforms to sports Arenas the
opening ceremony for the Rio Olympics
will take place behind me in the Maraka
Stadium which cost around half a billion
dollarss to renovate for this year's
World Cup much of that money went to OD
the contractor but at a company that's
generating around $40 billion in annual
revenues these high-profile projects may
be more about generating positive PR
than they are about profit across town
the company leads a joint venture that's
digging the city's new subway line it's
exactly the kind of complex
infrastructure project that with public
financing has pushed up oder br's
profits how important a government
contracts when it comes to construction
and infrastructure it's very very
important actually they are mainly
builders for the state for different
levels of the
state for firms like oder BR the
Brazilian state has become a highly
valued customer and consequently
political campaign contributions have
become a valuable business
tool a 2014 study found that for every
Brazilian Real Construction firm spent
on an earlier congressional election
they won up to 39 real in government
contracts when candidates they back from
the party succeeded during the 2010
election cycle campaign contributions
from oder BR companies topped 22 million
Us doll according to this election's
most recent figures which are now almost
7 weeks out of date oder BR and its
subsidiaries have donated to both
presidential candidates $3.3 million Us
in total if any of the candidates win
the election they will have to continue
to to uh invest in infrastructure and
the the game with the builders want to
be different soaring public costs and
spending on World Cup stadiums provoked
popular protests that began last year
before the economy began dipping into
recession and since economic growth will
hardly get faster higher stronger here
anytime soon this weekend's winning
presidential candidate May Ponder more
privately financed projects like Ilia
Pura in the hope they prove a bit more
popular